[Music]
and don't eat squirrels news oh really
I always wanted to do that I feel like
there would be like a rabbit you'd know
like rabbits in a rough way is rabbit a
rodent
oh no it's uh what's a [ __ ] thing
it's a marmoset I wrote it yeah I think
it is considered a pest because with the
Fontan I eat people's farms and like
people's like crops and stuff I think a
lot of people use squirrels but we're
just talking about like for this
particular whoa
Oh like there was like poisoned
squirrels would you eat squirrel no got
it
submit about five to six oh five so your
phone number four oh five to six oh five
oh four oh five no like that's like a
Cerrillos area I think four or five to
six old Otto squared
home of the honest word that's what
branding does yes Homer does a man
contracted a rare fatal disease from
eating squirrel brains
oh boy in school rings maybe he lives in
the wild like Joe wants to live he
should have cooked it thoroughly [ __ ]
head and he started scooping in with the
school and had a bacteria in it he
squeezed like toothpaste so that's like
go-gurt no so that squirrel was
definitely infected obviously and I
don't think cooking in a certain way
would even help it oh really
like it just it had that it was just
similar to mad cow disease do you guys
remember that more 80s and 90s it was
like crazy
so yeah like with mad cow disease
anything it's just it's contaminated
because when I used to sterilize
instruments surgical instruments and
there was this one patient that came in
and did have it we had to throw away all
the instruments we couldn't even hit the
doorway yeah we had to use a special
kind that we can just dispose of so
there's some things out there that even
fire can't [ __ ] take
like in nature yeah so this dude here he
he was a four he is a New York hunter
and he a New York hunter I just pictured
him in a city with a bow and arrow
[ __ ] killing pigeons and squirrels
squirrels what got fun paulien albinius
he's probably preaching about how like
squirrels are perfectly good food right
here yeah what the [ __ ] is he doing in
Central Park just shooting out squirrels
in New York can you believe the capital
of New York is Albin II know I cannot
believe that is that stunning it's like
dude I mean the fact of New York City is
real Sacramento I think they purposely
picked shitty capitals so that if anyone
tries to invade us they like here city
that Oh genius is out there like we have
taken al Bini in New York
you are truly Sacramento is a fine City
it was my city in my hometown yeah well
what to do there asleep and tell me what
to do in Sacramento Midtown I need
something to sleep too but ton of beer
[ __ ] tuna oh yeah aren't you from Santa
Barbara the [ __ ] [ __ ] really gorgeous
Beach College party town so everyone's
like it's party six hour just to party
thank you Tim I was boring as [ __ ] and
you're also adult now so good looking at
exactly boy in Sacramento would rather
be in Santa Marta
we were you from San Diego or where else
postcards from Santa Barbara like pretty
like he says oh Sid you where are you
from
we were you was what you did Virginia to
me was you can Texas yeah yeah when he
was 12
Virginia come on what about Virginia's
beautiful first it mental is this show
dude Virginia to Sacramento come on
Steve you're out of your [ __ ] money
get a Sacramento is gorgeous from
Virginia to Sacramento you know what
you know jigna Virginia you should take
pictures of set for the elves there's
not much to do there yet Appalachian
[ __ ] man [ __ ] outta here
Virginia I you Virginia Richie you know
what did you know I sold I am on
Sacramento David I could drink a [ __ ]
ton of beer then Midtown fantastic the
most amount of dispensaries out there to
ship to the [ __ ] weed we have yeah I
can't get that anywhere else in
California either no way better in
Sacramento my friend David so
[ __ ] Santa Barbara is known for
having the dankest weed not that I smoke
I don't but I know that we're known for
that I like Santa Barbara first of all
dankest get the [ __ ] out of here
whoa Sacramento baby we have the [ __ ]
highest crime rate in California right
now it's getting like capita yeah it's
getting up there right also know for
[ __ ] mozzie this dude mozzie
shout-out to mozzie
[ __ ] he is the rapper right now baby
Kendrick Lamar husband [ __ ] [ __ ]
crazy
dude dude the idea of a rapper be like
yo I'm from Sacramento it's like damn
that does not sound good cuz you're the
closer
yeah [ __ ] addy Virginia rappers is
pretty funny to him until I [ __ ] die
do you rip it up baby I gotta say the
tourism and board is gonna contact Union
billion hey can you knock it off
people are not wanting to come to Santa
Barbara on this right now dude who loves
Sacramento everybody Barbara Virginia
where are you I never been to Virginia
Virginia scooty beautiful doe cave you
been to DC no I am okay well it's like
DC it's like cherry blossoms and [ __ ]
cherry blossom because we can't get that
anywhere else either yes you can the art
there are a bunch of cherry blossoms
make sure that it's all the city of
trees dedicated I love my [ __ ] city
no you don't know you don't know you
can't you can't tell something about
someone city because that's like their
gang yeah yep yep
see so the Baba Airport well it sucks
you could talk [ __ ] on Virginia to me I
think is all fo the squirrel brains guy
New York squirrel a squirrel brain New
York hunt one year old man so like he
likes to hunt and he likes to eat a lot
of animals every hunt and so he was
eating the squirrel he apparently
consumed the brains of at least one
squirrel and it's the brain that's just
like a weird psycho killer type of thing
to do he had it coming there's like a
dominance thing like I'm gonna eat this
animals brain yes freely
only hunt squirrels no he has other
things but or maybe he likes brain
tacos maybe it's just that they they
narrowed it down to where it was he got
this disease it's called CDJ or CJ demon
CJD
kruetzfeldt Jakob
and that sounds like somebody's a name
it's the last guy that died from its
world race yeah right what an honor
yeah so this affects about 1 in 1
million people worldwide yeah
when those things happen it's so sad
because it's always like oh you are the
chosen one sorry is it one out of a
million people that hunted squirrels are
one out of a million people in general
but don't give a [ __ ] about this doesn't
happen just from squirrels like that's
the thing like it'll whichever animal
eats another animal that has this
disease that's how they contract advice
if he ate an animal I had it it's just
squirrel like do our squirrels ok with
the disease and the humans I didn't even
know squirrels ate other animals I
thought there's a vegetation like
insects I should don't eat not as
insects had it can I get this from you
know where that squirrel even got it
from did I get can you get this from
heating up frozen food at Trader Joe's
I don't know cuz I hope I sure hope not
let me tell you because basically a
program my whole survival yeah I think
microwaves kill the [ __ ] out of
everything living so it's ok especially
oatmeal Joe Oh like argue against
microwaving you don't [ __ ] cook oh
the microwave Virginia that makes me sad
I do it because the oats don't get
cooked the oats don't get cooked you
know but you want to look them a little
undercooked cuz the fiber probably yeah
I like that little bit like it cook you
some oatmeal and you're gonna be like
whoa oh my god I've been cooking o Sole
bra do you do the 20 minute version I do
it on the stove I do it on the stove too
but there's a 20 minutes though version
and there's like a five minutes so
version which is mine only takes me as
as fast as it boils as fast as it boils
I got oh so you've got the old-fashioned
oats
welcome back to oats talk there are let
us know what you guys will you guys do
your oats what's the last conversation
with legs
pickles pickles for four and a half all
right so you're trying to beat the
record that's the wall record tell us so
the symptoms are forgetfulness trouble
with vision Oh Steve has this disease
through the behavior and lack of
coordination
oh yeah that's Stevie let's just
describe to all my tres no this is me in
the later stages see JD can cause
blindness involuntary movements dementia
like mental illness and even coma so
very interesting yes they will die so
it's not curable Jesus yeah I guess not
because they are saying that and so it's
happening is that these infectious
proteins called prions they attack the
brain tissue and then they leave spongy
holes in the brain and so it's pretty
much like eating your brain do this it
reminds me of a video I just saw about
have you guys seen it popping up in
everyone's feet this this lady spills
pure mercury on her hand and that like
it just like ate her brain what yeah
from her hand yeah yeah so like she was
a scientist and she was one of the only
scientists that was working with this
pure form of mercury this chemist and
she was wearing gloves but she
accidentally spilled like two drops on
her glove and it they didn't notice at
the time but it actually goes through
gloves and it was only on her skin for
like 20 minutes but she started like
losing all of coordination so she
couldn't even like do anything after
about you know five weeks or so and then
she stopped remembering words and she
just went into like a coma state and
basically mercury was in her fat like
it's good stored in the fat you should a
multiple
your brain is made of mostly fat so
anything that is like a lip it's like a
lip subtype of something whatever and
it's it's stored in like the yeah
because they try to take out of her
blood and they could take it out her
blood and that was fine but it it didn't
change any of her symptoms because when
most of it was in her brain what do we
use mercury for we shouldn't we should
let mama turfs
in a vault and [ __ ] sent it into the
Sun you should use it for a warfare it
was supposed to be like the elixir of
life or some [ __ ] right that's what they
there was an emperor that [ __ ] drank
that [ __ ] and die that's the opposite of
life how come we don't serve our garbage
to the Sun I actually looked that [ __ ]
up cuz I thought this was supposed to
have sit gonna take too long it just
takes it's way too much [ __ ] money
yeah and there's too much fossil fuel we
don't have enough fossil fuel so once I
can cheap and get to space because
starts chucking our garbage of the
saucer movie all planets of garbage oh
yeah yeah so if we could figure out a
great one plan out instead of getting a
meteor shower they'll just get a garbage
shower the big what is all this it's
America's garbage
[Music]
[Music]
you